you're on legion okay all right and you
have a role where this is this made no
sense to me but it's a rule that was not
technically written for a young woman is
that right yeah and the pilot script it
was written for a middle-aged man I
don't get how that happens at all I mean
you're not someone who's like a
shape-shifter or anything right you're
in in the know I would never shape-shift
yeah yeah so they write a role for a man
in his 50s and you read for it and you
get it well no I didn't read for it but
I met with Noah Hawley who wrote it and
I remember having coffee with him I was
on crutches at the time because I had
torn my ACL and I was I just I don't
know that has nothing to do with it but
maybe there was something in my behavior
made me think of you was like an older
man maybe that matches man yeah ordering
black coffee with no sugar know what it
was but he asked me to do it and I said
yes that is so cool yeah but you're not
playing an old me you're playing it so
it's it's like you have the attitude of
an older man I it's really complicated
and it's hard to explain that mm-hmm
so you'll just have to watch it and just
decide for yourself like
it's a great way of getting people to
watch the show I'm not going to tell you
you're just gonna have to figure it out
it's one of those shows it's really it's
very trippy and kind of hard to talk
about but yeah I have I am many things
and an old man is one of them
that's quotes going to follow you for
the rest of your life
you